PROFESSOR: My watch says five
after 2:00, so why don't we
get started?
This is going to be
a strange lecture.
I'm expecting some wise guy in
the back to say, all your
lectures are rather peculiar!
But I have a phone call from
Europe coming in sometime
around 2:15, 2:30.
Somebody's coming to visit us
next week, and we're going to
set up a seminar.
So I don't know exactly when
it's going to come in, but I
have to be in my office.
So what I will do is
adjourn at quarter
after, 20 past the hour.
And then so I don't keep you
here sitting restively
wondering when I'm going
to come back, we'll
adjourn until 3 o'clock.
So you seem to have been taken
longer and longer breaks
during intermission.
So I'll give you a full 3/4 of
an hour so you can get it out
of your systems.
And then, we'll take shorter
breaks from here on in.
OK this is going to
be pretty much our
last lecture on symmetry.
And we will begin, at least in
half of the next class on
Tuesday, to begin talking about
physical properties, and
in particular tensor
properties.
But I'd like to say a little
bit about the derivation of
space groups and take a look
at how this information is
tabulated for you by the kind
folks who prepare the
international tables.
And there are really very strict
parallels between what
we did in two dimensions.
And that's the reason why we
did it so thoroughly and
systematically, except that
there are three dimensions.
And because we are taking 32
point groups and putting them
into 14 lattices, there are a
lot more combinations to be
considered.
And there are a lot more of
them that are unique.
Also, they're a little bit more
difficult to visualize
and depict.
So there are some new
conventions in preparing a
representation of three
dimensional symmetries on a
sheet of paper or page of a book
which, of necessity, has
to be two dimensional.
So we'll go over some of
those conventions.
But the main reason for going
a little bit further is that
there is another surprise
lurking in there for us as
soon as we begin to combine
translation in three
dimensions with a symmetry
element.
But let me go through
in some detail the
monoclinic space groups.
So we have at our disposal
to decorate with symmetry
elements two lattices.
And they are a primitive
monoclinic lattice with two
translations, a and b, that
define an oblique net, and a
third translation, c, at right
angles to that net.
And then, either two choices
for a double cell--
and I'll draw these in
projection because I can do
both of them with one diagram.
Either this is a and b and the
extra lattice point is in the
center of the cell halfway
up from the base.
This would be body centered.
And that's represented by
I for innenzentriert.
In German, that's German
for body centered.
Or the alternative would be to
pick a cell like this, in
which case the extra lattice
point gets caught in the
center of one of the faces.
So this depiction here would
be a side centered lattice.
And it could have the extra
lattice point in the middle of
the face out of which b comes.
And in that case, the symbol
for the lattice is B. Or
alternatively, without changing
any of the nature of
the specialness of the lattice,
the extra lattice
point could be in the
middle of the face
out of which a comes.
And that would be
an A lattice.
With the first, setting with the
c axis unique, there is no
c lattice because the oblique
base of the cell would not
give us anything new if
it were centered.
All right, so there are
those two lattices.
And then, there are three
point groups.
And they were 2, m, and then a
combination of a twofold axis
perpendicular to
a mirror plane.
So it looks as though in
principle there are going to
be 6 combinations.
In point of fact, there are
a lot more because of the
surprise that we have
in store for us.
Before proceeding further,
though, let me ask
rhetorically the question.
Which lattice type would you
pick as the standard one?
And here, there's a major
decision that has to be made.
Should the labels on an
axes give a unique
symbol for the lattice?
In other words, if you have
the double cell for a
monoclinic crystal, should you
define the cell to make it
body centered always, or to
make it A centered or B
centered always?
Or should the labels be defined
by the relative
lengths of the axes?
So those are the two
possibilities.
And there's no right
or wrong way.
You pays your money and
you makes your choice.
And on pragmatic grounds,
this is the
convention that's followed.
And it's purely a pragmatic
decision because lattice
constants have been determined
for literally tens of
thousands of materials.
Sometimes, the lattice constants
are known and the
space group is not.
But it would be terrible if the
label that you applied to
the axis could be C attached
to the longest one, the
shortest one, or the
intermediate one.
It would be impossible to
calculate any database for
lattice constants displayed
by particular materials.
So there's all this-- this is
what the decision was made.
This is the decision that
was made many years ago.
And for monoclinic crystals,
the labeling of the axes is
determined by the c axis
being the unique axis.
That is, the axis that is along
the twofold axis or
perpendicular to the
mirror plane.
And then, the labels b and c are
defined by magnitude of b
greater than the
magnitude of a.
So I inherently drew this is
in the proper fashion.
So the labels are applied
to monoclinic
crystals in that fashion.
The price you pay for that is
that the symbol for the
lattice for a monoclinic crystal
that has the double
cell could either be A, B, or
I depending on the relative
lengths of the axes.
If these were the two shortest,
it would be a body
centered lattice.
On the other hand, if this and
this were the shortest pair,
then it would be a side
centered lattice.
So the symbol for the lattice
type will bounce around
depending on the dimensions
of the translations.
So that's a complication
in the space groups.
In the two dimensional
plane group, that
issue never came up.
We just took B greater than A
for the rectangular and the
oblique nets.
OK, so let me do quickly
a couple of the
monoclinic space groups.
Let's take a twofold axis and
put it into a primitive
monoclinic net.
And this is exactly the same as
our plane group, P2, with
the twofold axes extended
parallel to the c translation.
So we would have twofold axes in
all of these orientations.
And that's simply P2, little p
in two dimensions, with the
twofold axes extended
normal to the plane
of the plane group.
So this is p2.
This is capital P2.
And that is way we
distinguish plane
groups from space groups.
So the symbol for the lattice
is a capital symbol for the
space groups.
So I didn't have to use any
new combinations theorems.
I simply say there's
a third translation
perpendicular to the net.
So everything protrudes
out of the plane group
into a third dimension.
Let me now combine a twofold
axis this a and this b and
this c with a lattice that is
not the primitive lattice but
one of the double cells.
And I'll take it, for
convenience, to be the body
centered flavor because
it's easier to draw.
And the operation that we've
added to the lattice, if this
is a combination of a twofold
axis, is the symbol A pi.
And I know what happens if
I combine A pi with a
translation that is
perpendicular to
the rotation axis.
I get a new rotation axis, B pi,
that's halfway along the
perpendicular part of
the translation.
And that's where all
of these additional
twofold axes came in.
But if a lattice is a body
centered lattice, there is now
a translation that goes up to
the centered lattice point.
So what's that going to be?
What is T followed by A pi
followed by T, where T is 1/2
A plus 1/2 of B?
And that is a part that is
perpendicular to the axis, and
then a third component, c, which
is parallel to the axis.
As with all these theorems, what
you do is you draw it out
once and for all and see what
it turns out to be.
So let's do that.
Let's say that this is the
translation that goes up to
the point 1/2, 1/2, 1/2.
Here is the parallel part--
the perpendicular
part, rather.
This is 1/2 of A
plus 1/2 of B.
And then, we have a part
that's parallel to the
rotation operation, A pi.
And that is 1/2 of c.
So let's just do it.
Here's my first object
number one.
It's right handed.
I'll rotate 180 degrees
to get a second one
that's right handed.
And then, I will translate
it up to here.
And here sits the third one.
It's also right handed.
How do I get from
one to three?
It's not really clear
how I do that.
And again, I'll draw it in
projection because this is
looking pretty messy in
three dimensions.
So here's my first one.
I rotate 180 degrees to
get a second one.
The chirality is all the same.
And then, I translate
up to this point.
So if this one is at z and this
one is at z, this one
here will sit at z plus 1/2.
And this is the third one.
Anybody got any idea?
Can't be reflection.
They're of the same chirality.
It can't be translation
because the
orientation is different.
Yes, sir?
AUDIENCE: Then it has to be
some form of rotation.
PROFESSOR: Right, has to be.
But how do we get the object up
to a different elevation?
Well, we've stumbled headlong
over a new type of operation,
just as we discovered the glide
plane when we started
putting mirror planes into a
lattice in combination with
translation.
The only way I can get from the
first to the third is to
rotate 180 degrees about exactly
the same point that I
would have before, namely at
1/2 of the part of the
translation that is
perpendicular to the operation.
But then before putting it
down, I've got to take a
second step.
I've got to slide it up by a
translation component that is
parallel to the axis about
which I've rotated.
So to complete my theorem,
A alpha followed by a
translation that has a
perpendicular part plus a
parallel part is a new type
of operation that involves
rotating through 180 degrees.
And this is located at 1/2
of T perpendicular.
But it has a translation
component which I'll call
generically tau.
And tau is equal to the
parallel part of the
translation.
So if I separate out this new
sort of operation in all of
its grandeur, what it does is
it takes a first object,
rotates us 180 degrees, does
not yet put it down, first
slides up by the amount tau.
Doing the operation, again
rotates it 180 degrees,
doesn't yet put it down,
slides it up by tau.
Doing it again moves us to
another one up here.
So what we've generated is a
helical spiral of objects
about the central axis about
which we're rotating.
And this is a new two step
operation that's called a
screw axis.
There is a persistent rumor that
it derives its name from
the effect that it has
on 360 quizzes.
But that is just
an ugly rumor.
There's nothing to
that at all.
So this is a new two step
operation that we'll call, in
general, A alpha tau.
And what it will do is to
generate a screw like
distribution of objects.
For those of you who have come
in late, since you've been
demonstrating a predilection
towards longer and longer
breaks, we're going to adjourn
now and have a 40 minute break
so you can get it out
of your system.
And we will resume at exactly
3 o'clock sharp.
And we will launch into an
elucidation of the nature of
screw axes.
And again, for those of you who
were not here at the very
start of class, the reason is
that I have a phone call that
had to come in about this time
of day and no other time.
So rather than keep you
shifting, wondering whether
I'm coming back, we'll start at
three when I should be done
with my business.
OK, so that's it.
You missed all the important
discussion of what's going to
be on the next quiz, and nobody
will tell you because
they want to keep class
average down.
All right, so sorry for the
longer than usual interlude,
but we'll start again
promptly at 3:00.